every time you get off work early a
corona gets its lime every time you see
that cute girl from apartment 3c at the
bar a corona gets its lime hey
so uh can i buy you a drink every time
she rejects your advances and asks about
your wedding ring a corona gets its lime
how about you buy your wife a drink get
lost creep when you're sent to a shame
spiral that sends you on one of the
darkest benders of all time
oh yeah a few coroners are getting limed
and when you come to three days later
your kid's custody hearing you might not
be getting visitation rights but a crisp
cold coronas get in line your honor that
is absurd on what ground please remain
seated no i am not going to sit here and
take this sit down sir get your hands up
but you fast
[Applause]
every time you're released from prison
after a six-month stint for assaulting a
bailiff you guessed it a corona is
getting live